Aaron Goodman:
This talk is about
the upcoming extension
system for Google Chrome.
My name's Aaron Goodman.
To give you a little bit
of background about myself,
so you kind of know
who you're talking to...
before I started working
at Google,
I created the Greasemonkey
Firefox extension,
which was about five years
ago now.
And it was originally
intended to be a quick hack
that only a few
of my friends would appreciate,
the JavaScript hackers
that I knew.
And I didn't really expect it
to be popular,
but it became
extremely popular,
much to my surprise.
And that's kind of what
eventually to led me
being interested in working on
extensions for Chrome.
In between then and now,
I've been working on Gears
which is another project
at Google, and Chrome.
[clears throat]
So before I dive in
and get started,
I wanna make
a few quick caveats.
What you're about to see here
is alpha code,
pre-alpha code, even.
This is a early
developer preview.
We're not making any extensions
available
to the general public today.
Ever since...
since Chrome is open source,
we do everything
in the open.
We've done all our designing
in the open,
and it's the same
with extensions.
Since we started the project,
we did all of our design
documents completely in the open
and so it hasn't been
a secret
that we're working on
extensions for Chrome.
And since it's not a secret,
we figured that since
this is a developer conference,
it would be cool to come here
and give an update
about where we're at with
the statuses of the project
and sort of what
the focus of it is,
how it works,
and what's cool about it.
So the specific agenda today
is that we're gonna build
an extension together.
We're gonna start from scratch
from an empty page,
build a simple extension
up to something
that's moderately functional,
and along the way,
I'm gonna show you
three of what I think
are the coolest things
about the design
of the Chrome Extension system.
But first I want to step back
and give some context
about why we're even doing
an extension system for Chrome.
'Cause I think that kind of
will set the stage
for some of the decisions
that we made
about how it's implemented.
There's some pretty good
reasons why
you would not want to do
an extension system
for a browser.
And...if there's
any security people around,
I'm sure you can think
of some of them.
But there's quite a few.
First of all,
it can be a security problem.
The browser has become
the most important
piece of software on computers,
and it's the interface
through which you access
all of your private
and sensitive data on the web.
And so naturally
adding third-party code
into that software
is something that should be
thought about carefully.
There's also...there can be
robustness issues.
Application developers
are typically nervous
about adding plugins,
extensions, whatever,
to their system
because if there's a problem
with a plugin or an extension,
users don't typically
understand
that the problem
is with the extension.
They just think that
the application is busted,
and they're just mad at
the application in general.
So that can cause--
application vendors
are typically reluctant
to add plugins because
they end up getting blamed
for problems with the plugins.
Another reason why not
to do an extension system
is maintenance.
Every time you add
an extension API to a product,
you create a maintenance problem
for yourself.
Because you can never take back
and extension API.
Once you create one
and people start using it,
you're married to it
and it exists forever,
and you have to support it
forever.
And this can become
a big problem.
It can make it
so it's very difficult
to upgrade your product
and add new features to it
or change features
because there's features that
are attached to extension APIs,
and you can't modify
the extension APIs
because it would break
all the extensions,
and you don't wanna do that.
So these are all reasons
why you would not want to do
an extension system.
But we are doing one.
So why is that?
Well, the obvious reason
is that you made us.
The very first day
we launched Chrome,
it was September 2.
The 18th bug that was reported
was that Chrome does not
have an extension system.
[chuckling]
And...[laughs]
There were a lot of bugs
created that day.
So this was created,
you know,
minutes
after we launched Chrome.
[laughs]
And within days,
800 people starred it
and added such helpful
comments as,
"Repose for me...
There's no extension
system on my computer."
[laughter]
So thanks for helping us
track that down.
[laughs]
And we eventually
had to close the bug
because it became
totally useless
because there were
800 comments on it.
So that's the obvious reason
is that...
especially because
of the great work
that Mozilla has done
with Firefox,
they've really shown
how important and crucial
a vibrant add-on
eco system is for a browser
and since Firefox,
users just have come to expect
that browsers have powerful
extension systems.
So that's the obvious reason
why we're doing one.
But there are
some other good reasons.
And there are reasons
that sort of counterweight
all the reasons
not to do one.
And there are reasons
that the Chrome team,
the Google Chrome team
is especially interested in.
First of all,
an extension system
helps keep Google Chrome
minimal.
One of the cool features
of Chrome
that we really like
and that we're proud of
is that Chrome has this really
minimal slick interface,
and we think that
this is a reason
that people like
using Chrome,
and we want
to keep it that way.
But the problem is that
in order to keep it that way,
we have to have a very high
bar for features
that we'll add to Chrome.
And we have a rule of thumb
on the project
that we won't add a feature
to the main interface of Chrome
unless we think that
it will be used
by a vast majority
of users of Chrome.
Not a simple majority.
Not a significant majority.
Almost all users.
And that creates
a huge problem,
because there's
tons of features
that a lot of users
would want--
a majority of users would want--
but we won't add them
to Chrome
because we're trying
to keep it minimal.
Extensions
help with this problem
because ideally,
with a good extension system,
we can create a customized
browser for every user.
Every user can have
the features that they need
and none of the features
they don't want.
As an example of this,
a simple example,
imagine a feature
that integrates with Skype.
People who use Skype
would probably really like
the ability to have phone
numbers on web pages highlighted
so they could click on them
and it would dial in Skype.
It's a great feature.
People who use Skype
would love this.
But people who don't use Skype
would think this feature's
totally useless,
and it would just be
noise to them.
So this is just one example
of all kinds of features
that come up like this
that some users want,
some users don't,
and extension systems
really help solve this problem.
Another reason
that the Google Chrome team
wants to do extensions
is because it helps us prototype
new feature ideas.
I mentioned that
we won't add something to Chrome
unless it's gonna be used
by most users.
But how do we know
that a feature will be used
by most users?
Sometimes it's not clear.
There can be arguments
within the team
about whether a feature's
important or not.
And if we just add it
to the product and ship it,
it will be hard for us
to take it away,
because people get used to it
and they don't want us
to remove it.
So even if it's not
successful,
it would be hard for us
to remove it later.
Extension system
helps with this because
we can implement a feature
as an extension,
put it out there,
let people install it,
and if it becomes
wildly successful,
then we know
that it was a good idea
and we add it
to the main Chrome UI.
Otherwise,
it just stays an extension.
So with that context...
I'm gonna dive in and start
building up a sample extension.
What you're gonna see here
requires what's called the
Dev Channel release of Chrome.
If you're not familiar,
Chrome has three releases.
Three channels
is what we call them.
And these channels
are available all the time,
so there's always three
different releases of Chrome
available at any given
point in time.
There's the stable channel,
which is what almost
everyone has.
If you go to Google.com/Chrome
and you install Chrome,
this is what you get,
the stable channel.
There's also a beta channel
which is released
much more frequently.
It's released
about once a month, and...
the beta channel
has all the features
that are expected to become
the next stable release
of Chrome.
And since it's not yet stable,
it has a few more bugs,
it may crash
more frequently,
it may be a little bit slower--
things like that.
And then finally,
there's the Dev Channel,
and the Dev Channel
is like the Wild West.
The Dev Channel
is released every week, and...
unless there's some
major problem,
and it has minimal testing,
and it has all the features
that we're experimenting with.
So some of these features
may not ever make it
to the stable release.
We may decide
that we don't like them
or we may change them,
and it's a lot less stable.
But the upside
is that the Dev Channel
has all the newest work,
and since extensions is on-going
and we're giving this talk
in the middle of the development
of the extensions project,
the Dev Channel's
what you need to use this stuff.
You also need to add
a custom flag
to your chrome.xe shortcut,
and all of this is described
on a how-to document
that we've put up
that you can read
that will help you get started
writing an extension.
So if you do a Google search
for Chrome Extensions HOWTO,
click on the first result,
it'll take you to a page
that details how to get started
writing your first extension.
And it covers
these prerequisites.
So we can finally get started
writing our extension.
I said that we're gonna cover
three of the coolest things
about the extension system,
and the first one,
the most important one,
and the one that we're most
excited about
and is sort of the linchpin
that the whole system
revolves around,
is that in Chrome
extensions are web pages.
What I mean by that
extensions in Chrome
are written using
the exact same technologies
that you use to write
web pages--
HTML, CSS, and JavaScript.
It's not inspired
by these technologies,
but extensions actually are
web pages.
So all the skills,
all the tools that you use
to write web pages
and that you're familiar with
are immediately applicable
to writing extensions in Chrome,
and you don't need
to relearn anything.
What does that mean, to have
an extension be a web page?
Well, let's take a look.
In Chrome,
extensions are basically
a package, a zip file,
of HTMLs, CSS, and JavaScript.
And there can be as many
of these files as you want.
And then there's one file
called a manifest
that ties the whole thing
together
and declares information
about the extension
such as its name,
its description, its version,
and the features
that it's using.
So in this right window here,
I have started
a basic extension.
And right now the extension
is totally empty.
It has nothing in it
except for my manifest file.
I open this up in my editor,
and...I'll make the screen font
a little bigger.
And you can see that
this manifest is JSON.
It's a format
that most web developers
should be familiar with.
And right now,
it has two keys,
which is the bare minimum
required for an extension
that just declares
this name and this version.
And what I'm gonna do now
is I'm gonna add my first
feature to my extension.
And one of the features
that we support
is called toolstrips,
so I'm gonna add one toolstrip.
And...it's an HTML file.
And I'll call it
my_toolstrip.html.
So I save my manifest.
I'll create a new HTML file...
And I'll save that
as my_toolstrip.html.
And now to do these demos,
I'm gonna use a separate
instance of Chrome
just so that I don't lose
my place in the presentation.
Again, this works with the
development version of Chrome,
so you don't need
a special build of it.
So I start my Chrome.
And you can see
that there's now a toolbar
along the bottom part
of Chrome,
and my extension,
my toolstrip
shows up there.
And it's not
too exciting yet,
doesn't do anything.
It just has some text.
But I can prove that this
really is an extension
by right-clicking on it.
It brings up
Chrome's Inspector,
which is exactly the same
inspector that you use
to de-bug web pages.
It works exactly the same way.
You can expand the elements.
Oops. Aah.
Let me try that again.
[laughs]
And when you hover
over the elements,
it highlights them
just like the regular
web inspector does.
And this highlights
a great reason why
we want to use web pages
for extensions,
because we didn't have to
write any new tools,
and you don't have to learn
any new tools.
Everything works exactly
the same way
as it does when you're
writing web pages.
So if you already know
how to use Chrome's Inspector,
you know how to use it
for extensions too.
Now, since this is HTML,
I can use any HTML features.
It can actually do more
than just print out
snarky comments.
So I can add an icon,
and it works exactly
the same way as HTML.
I have an icon here
I'm gonna copy out of my...
folder of samples
and into my extension.
And also,
because it is a web page,
the development cycle
is just like a web page.
You can just reload it,
and you see the new content.
Of course, the reload button
doesn't work
because the reload button
is for the tab.
But you can reload an extension
in multiple ways.
One way is to just create
a new window,
so I create a new window,
and you can see
my icon showed up.
Another way that I like to do
is I just use the console
and use the JavaScript API
to do a reload.
So I type location of reload
and you can see
my toolstrip reloaded.
So Chrome Extensions
are HTML, CSS, and JavaScript.
To recap,
extensions are packages,
zip files basically,
that contain these files.
Each piece of UI
in your extension,
such as toolstrips
that I just showed,
sidebars, when we have those
in the future,
all of these things are fully
functioning web pages,
and so they work
exactly the same as web pages.
You can use
the same debugging tools,
the same JavaScript libraries,
the same techniques,
all the CSS hacks that
you've learned over the years
work exactly the same way.
And if you prefer to use jQuery,
you can use jQuery.
It will work the same way.
If you like Prototype
or MochiKit,
you can use those.
They all work the same way
as they do on web pages
because extensions
really are web pages.
From the point of view
of the library,
the library does not even know
that it's in an extension.
So it's guaranteed to work.
And just like web pages,
there's an easy iterative
development cycle
for extensions.
All you do is reload
and you see your new content.
There's no need to restart
or recompile anything.
Now, you may have noticed
that when I
put that simple HTML
in my HTML file,
it did not look
like what you would expect
if you loaded that into
a normal web page.
It had a different style.
It had blue text
instead of black.
It was arial or sans-serif font
instead of serif.
It had a blue background,
etcetera.
The reason that
that happened
is because we add default CSS
to the extensions
to make them look good
with the Chrome UI.
And we do that because,
again,
one of the things that
we're most proud of in Chrome
and that we really like
is that it has this sleek,
modern interface
and we didn't want extensions
to ruin that.
We wanted extensions in Chrome
to still have
that same aesthetic.
And at the same time,
we want extensions to be
really easy to write.
And having every developer
have to worry about
writing the right CSS
to fit in with Chrome's UI
seemed really difficult
and also seems like
it would result in
everyone doing it
slightly differently...
which wouldn't look good.
So we inject this default CSS
into your extension
so that by default
you don't have to do anything.
Your extension
will just look good
and fit in with
the Chrome UI.
I can show you another
example of how that works.
We have this...
we have some special CSS classes
that you can use...
to get effects
to make it fit in better
with Chrome's UI.
And one of them
is this toolstrip button class.
So I can create a div
with that class name...
and I'll restart my extension.
And you can see now
that when I hover over this,
is has this nice blue
rounded outline.
The spacing is also
a little bit better.
And actually,
you might notice
that it's exactly
the same look and feel
as the native bookmark buttons.
So it looks exactly the same.
You can't even tell
that it's HTML.
And there's actually
a lot of little details
that go into doing that.
The corners of these are rounded
and anti-aliased.
and there's a faint white
shadow on the blue text.
And it would be hard
to do this.
As an extension developer,
it would take a lot of time
to get it right.
And if we ever changed
the look of Chrome,
your extension wouldn't
look right with the new look,
and so this makes things
really easy.
You just add this class.
You don't have to write any CSS.
And your toolstrip
will fit in naturally.
Another thing
you can do, of course,
is if you...
what we're trying to do here
is to make it easy
to write extensions
that fit in with Chrome's UI
without doing anything extra.
But if you want to go
above and beyond
and you want to do
something crazy,
you can use the full power
of CSS,
so you can do
whatever you want.
If for some reason
you want to have
an ugly, red background
for your extension,
you're free to do that.
We're not gonna
try and stop you.
You can just add
any CSS you want...
and you get a red background.
Very exciting.
I'm gonna remove that,
'cause it's ugly.
But you can also do
more interesting things.
WebKit is the rendering engine
that Chrome uses, of course,
and WebKit has all these
really cool
experimental CSS features.
And some of them are animations,
filters, transformations.
And you can use all of these
in extensions,
and they work
exactly the same way
because, again,
extensions are web pages.
So I can...this is
a little bit of CSS
that does a little animation.
And I can add this
to my extension.
And now when I start it,
if I hover over it,
It does a little dance,
very fun.
Didn't have to write
any JavaScript to do that.
Just comes for free...
by way of WebKit's
CSS features.
So that's fun.
And this is an example of how,
again,
using webpage technology
to write extensions
gives a lot of things
for free.
Anything that works in web pages
will work in extensions.
Oops.
[clears throat]
So another important--
You're gonna get tired
of hearing me saying,
"It's just like a web page,"
but this is something
that we're really excited about.
So sorry about that.
Another thing that web page
developers frequently use
is called XMLHttpRequest.
If you're a web developer
in the room,
you probably know
what this does
but for those who don't,
quick refresher is that
XMLHttpRequest,
commonly called XHR,
is basically the most important
API in web browsers today.
This is the API
that makes it possible
to do applications
like Gmail, Reader, and Maps.
And what it allows you to do
as a web developer
is request more data
from the server
without reloading the page.
So all of your applications
that you use,
like Maps,
when you scroll the map
and you see more tiles come in
dynamically
without updating the page,
this is the API
that makes that possible.
And so it's very important.
And since it's part of
a web page
it of course works
automatically with extensions,
and it works
exactly the same way.
And if you use any wrapper
scripts to use XHR, usually,
those will all work
exactly the same way.
But we did make
one minor addition
to XHR for extensions.
We made it work cross-domain.
So one of the main limitations
of XHR in regular web pages
is that it's limited
to the same domain.
If you serve a page
from google.com,
you can only request resources
with XHR
that are also on google.com.
And this is an important
security limitation.
It's there on purpose.
For web pages, you don't want
any random web page
that you happen
to browse across
to be able to request
resources
from gmail.com on your behalf.
That doesn't make sense.
But for extensions,
since you install extensions--
it's a conscious decision
to install an extension--
it does make sense
for an extensions to be able
to do things like this.
And so we enable this so that
extensions can do cool things,
cool mashups like request data
from different web services
and combine them and show you
interesting results.
The way this works is that...
in an extension,
you have to--
In a Chrome Extension,
you declare in the manifest
the domains
that you want to talk to.
And then cross-origin XHR
works exactly the same way
as regular XHR,
and it makes it possible
to request them.
So I can add this to my
extension that I'm building up.
And I have some...
the rest of the demos
in this...presentation...
some of them I'm gonna use
pre-written code.
The main reason
I'm doing this
is just because the code
is pretty straightforward
and it would be boring
for both of us,
for me to sit here
and write it in front of you.
So when the code is small
and I can write it live,
I'll do that.
But in this case,
there's about 20 lines,
and I didn't want to do that
while you were sitting here.
But there's no fooling here.
I hope you can see that
this is pretty straightforward
AJAX JavaScript code,
and it works exactly
the same way as web pages.
So what this code
is gonna do is...
it's gonna hook my extension
up to the Google Reader API.
And what I'm gonna do is
right now my extension
just has this static text
that says "oh, hai."
But I'm gonna change it
so that it connects
to the Google Reader API
and figures out
how many items
I have unread
in my reading list.
And once it gets the number
of unread items,
it's gonna update
my toolstrip,
the display on my toolstrip,
and show the number
of unread items.
And so I will always know
at all times
how many things
I'm waiting to read
that need to be read
in Google Reader,
which seems very useful.
Um...
one thing I want to call out
about this code, actually,
before I paste it in.
You may notice
that I'm using JSON here,
but there's no JSON library
in this code.
And the reason why
is because the V.18
has recently added
native JSON to V8,
so you no longer need to include
a JSON library in Chrome,
which is very cool.
And it's using a safe parser,
so there's
no eval happening here.
So the first thing
I'm gonna do
is update my manifest
to include the domain
that I want to talk to.
So I tell it that I want
to talk to google.com
because the Reader API
lives on google.com.
And the next thing
I'm gonna do is...
update my code
to call the Reader API.
Oh, also I'll take out
this animation.
Very fun but...
Okay...oh, one last thing.
I need to take out
my static text
and put in a place holder.
So you can see that
when the API call comes back,
it's gonna call setCount,
and setCount
will update the spam
that has the unread-count ID
with the number of items
in my...
in my reading list.
Make sure
that I spelled it right.
Good. So now...
I again restart my extension.
Aha! I have 607 items to read.
So...that's useful.
It would be more useful if
I could actually click on this
and have it do something.
Right now I just have to know
to go to reader.google.
That's not very good.
So I can just fix that
really quick
by just using regular
JavaScript.
So start it up again.
I click on it.
Hooray! Now I can go to Reader
and read the stuff.
[applause]
Now we're getting somewhere.
We have a quicker way
to access time wasting.
So, good.
[laughter]
Um...
So what else can you do?
Well, a frequent thing
that extension developers
want to do is store things.
Imagine that your extension
has settings,
and there's all these
different settings
that you can choose
about what things show up
in the extension.
You would need to store these
in the extension
when a user changes them
so that the next time
your extension starts up,
you can change the UI
in the right way.
Now...one thing
that we could do
in the design
of the extension system
is to add a settings API
that you could use
to store these things.
And that would work.
But what we realized
is that HTML5,
the new version of HTML already
has a local storage API.
It actually has two.
So...
so there's no need
to add a settings API
for Chrome Extensions,
and we can just reuse the one
that's an HTML5.
So this local storage
is not yet
completely implemented
in Chrome.
There's a team working on it.
But when it shows up,
you'll be able to use it
in extensions
exactly the same way
as you use it in web pages.
And so if you already know
how to use this API
from experience with
other browsers that have it,
you won't have to learn
anything new
to use it in extensions.
And if you've never
used it before
and you learn it
for extensions,
then it will just work
automatically with web pages.
You'll be able to reuse
that knowledge in web pages
all the time.
And this is another example
of why it's a cool idea,
I think,
to use web page technology
for the extension system,
because the web
is currently in a period
where it's evolving
very rapidly.
All the browser vendors
are doing great work
and pushing things forward.
And every time one of these
new features
shows up in Chrome
for web pages,
it will just automatically
show up for extensions,
and it makes my job
a lot easier
because there's
less work to do.
Now, there are some APIs,
some features
that we want to enable
extension developers to do
that are not
part of HTML or CSS.
Mostly, these revolve around
things that we want extensions
to be able to control
in the browser.
So we want extensions to be able
to control the history system,
the bookmark system,
the tabs and window system,
to interact
with the omnibox.
And all these features
don't really make sense
to thumb through HTML,
because they have
nothing to do with HTML,
and they would be unlikely
to ever be standardized,
so it doesn't make sense
to do that.
And so we've added
extension browser APIs
that you can access
when you're in an extension.
And our philosophy
with these APIs
is around two main points--
that they should be
narrow and webby.
What I mean by narrow is
when you design an extension
system for a product,
you have to make one
decision early on,
one really important decision
which is
how wide your
API surface area will be.
How much functionality
will you expose?
One approach
is that you just expose
all of the internal functions
that make your product work
directly to extensions.
And that works really great.
It has a lot of upsides
because it means
that your extension system
will be very powerful.
And it will have a lot of APIs.
Because everything that you use
to build the product
is automatically available
to extension developers,
and so extension developers
will be able to do
all those things too.
And...that's good,
But it also has a downside,
and the downside is that
if you ever change the way
your product is implemented,
you change
those internal functions.
You automatically break the
extensions that were using it,
and that's bad.
And so in Chrome,
what we decided to do
is instead do narrow APIs.
So we go through each of
the major subsystems of Chrome
that we want to allow
extension developers
to interact with,
and we look at them
and we try and decide
what would be
an interesting API for this?
And we design them
specifically,
and the advantage of that
is that...
we can commit
to supporting these.
So we will never
have to, hopefully,
turn off extensions,
disable them,
because a future version
of Chrome
doesn't support the APIs
that they use.
We can commit to supporting
these APIs forever
because they're not just things
that are part of our
implementation internally.
They're things that we
explicitly decided to expose.
Another advantage
of the narrow APIs
is that
we get to design them.
If you just expose
all of your internal functions
directly
to extension developers,
they just get the interfaces,
whatever internal functions
you use,
and a lot of times, internal
code isn't really designed
to be really nice
and really easy to use
because it doesn't
really matter
because it's only used
by the product team.
But we wanted
our extension system
to be really easy to use,
really accessible to developers,
especially web developers,
and we wanted it to be webby.
We wanted it to feel like
it fit in with the web platform.
And so doing narrow APIs
gives us an opportunity
to do this.
We can design these things
in a way that we think
makes sense to web developers.
So...I got a few demos
about browser APIs.
First, I'm just gonna do
a really quick one
that isn't terribly useful
but will give you a feel
for how it works.
We'll create a bookmark
in the toolbar.
So I'll call it
chrome.bookmarks.create.
And its URL would be...
I don't know.
What's a good site?
Um...
And parentID is the level
in the bookmark's hierarchy
that we want the bookmark
to show up in,
and I just happen to know
that the parentID
of the toolstrip is 1.
Or the bookmarks bar is 1.
But you can also discover this
through the API
with a few more lines of code.
And so with just that one
line of code,
I'm gonna add a bookmark
to the bookmark bar.
So I restart my extension,
and there we go.
Hooray.
Now, that's not
terribly interesting.
What if, instead,
we add one bookmark
for every item that
I'm subscribed to in Reader?
So we contact the Reader API,
find all the feeds
that I'm subscribed to,
and add a bookmark
for each one of those.
That seems at least
somewhat useful,
and that way,
if I really feel like reading
one particular feed,
I'll have a quick way
to access it.
So I have some code
for that.
And again, you can see
this is pretty short,
about 65 lines of
pretty typical JavaScript.
What it's gonna do is,
first step,
it's gonna get the entire
hierarchy of bookmarks
from the bookmark system.
We're gonna put
all of the feed--
all of the bookmarks
in one folder.
So first we look for
that folder
and see if it already
exists.
And if it does,
we remove it.
And then we create
a new folder.
And then we fetch the feeds
that I'm subscribed to
from Reader,
and then once we get the feeds,
we parse the JSON.
And then for each feed
that I'm subscribed to,
create a bookmark
in the folder.
So I'll paste this code
into my toolstrip.
Once again,
I will start up Chrome.
And there it is.
So now I have this feeds folder,
and inside each one I have--
In this account, I'm only
subscribed to two feeds.
But if it was real life,
it would have a lot more.
So that's cool.
Now, the browser APIs,
there's an obvious tradeoff
here with going with narrow.
Obviously, it means
that we'll have less APIs
than a system
that uses a wide approach.
So that means that we're gonna
have to be really responsive
to the development community
and listen very carefully
and build things
that people need.
As to the exact list,
we don't know yet.
The list is to be determined.
This is an area
that we're actively working on.
And so it's still up in the air.
But obviously, we want the
extension system to be powerful.
We want people
to be able to do
everything
that they want to do with it,
and so there will be probably
a pretty big list of these APIs
that we'll build out.
And...so if you don't--
obviously, the items on here
is very short,
but if you don't see us
working on an API that you want,
definitely let us know.
Contact us
on Chromium-discuss,
because we know that this is
one of the parts of the system
that we need to listen
very carefully about
and so we want to hear
your feedback
about what APIs
you want to see.
And further, if you're
interested in working on Chrome,
if you're a C++ guy and you
wanna work on Google Chrome,
it is an open source project,
and this is an area in which
it's very easy for people
to come and join and help
because it's easy
to split these things up
and have people
working on different ones
without stepping on each other.
So the second cool thing,
I think,
about the extension system,
the design
of the extension system,
is its process model.
As you might recall,
Chrome is multiprocess.
It's one of the really cool
things about Chrome,
the really innovative things,
and one of
the key features of it.
And just as a refresher,
there's a lot of reasons
to do this,
but mostly the reason
why Chrome is multiprocess
is because web pages are
becoming more and more advanced,
more and more complicated,
and they become
a lot like applications.
And so just like applications,
it makes sense to run them
in separate processes
to protect them
from each other.
So if one web page crashes,
it doesn't crash
the other web pages.
It doesn't crash the browser.
If a plugin crashes,
it doesn't crash the browser,
etcetera.
It just makes sense.
There's also
security benefits for it.
It turns out
it doesn't require
a lot of operating
system permissions
to render a web page.
You don't really require
disc access,
you don't really
require network access,
all those things can be
abstracted away.
And so you can lock down
the processes
that render web pages
so that they don't have
any capabilities.
And what that means
is that
if a web page process
is compromised,
it can only get the permissions
that the original process had.
So you kind of contain
exploits that way.
It also sort of
counter-intuitively
leads to better
resource allocation.
Even though
a multiprocess browser
obviously requires
a little bit more resources,
it turns out that you get
better utilization,
because the operating system
is very good
at sharing resources fairly
amongst processes.
So if you have one web page
that's using a lot of CPU
or using a lot of memory,
it's okay because
most modern browser--
most modern operating systems
are very good at making sure
that all processes get
a fair access to the resources.
So extensions are multiprocess
for the exact same reason
or the exact same reasons.
Every extension in Chrome
has its own process,
and you get
the same benefits.
Extensions
can't crash each other,
they can't crash the browser,
they can't crash web pages.
If an extension is exploited,
the exploits are contained
and the malicious code only
gets access to the permissions
that the extension had itself,
and you get
better resource sharing.
So if an extension
is being badly behaved
and using a lot of CPU,
using a lot of memory,
it doesn't really affect
the rest of the browser
or the web pages
because the operating system
can share resources fairly.
Now, inside one of these
extension processes,
again, you have
multiple web pages.
Because every part
of an extension
is basically a web page.
So you can imagine that...
I showed you toolstrips.
An extension can have
multiple toolstrips.
It could have a sidebar.
The sidebar would be a web page.
You can open pop-up windows
in an extension,
and those could be
web pages.
You could have HTML
in the main tab area,
which would, of course,
be a web page, and so on.
So you can imagine,
a typical extension's
gonna end up with many
web pages running in it.
And additionally, if you have
multiple browser windows,
every browser window's
gonna get its full complement
of web pages
from each extension.
And this might seem like it
would lead to slow performance,
but remember that Chrome is,
like most modern browsers,
is optimized to run many
web pages at once.
Users of Chrome typically have
20, 30 tabs open at a time,
and so having a few extra
pages open
for an extension running
is not really that big a deal
and it's something that
Chrome's already optimized for.
Now...having
all these web pages
as part of your extension
running at the same time
leads naturally to the question
of how they can communicate.
For example, going back
to the settings example,
say you have the settings UI
where you...
users get to choose
all the various settings
for your extension,
when a setting has changed,
you probably want to tell
all the parts of your extension
that the setting changed
so they can update
their display.
Now, if you've ever
used IFrames in a web page,
you're familiar with the kind
of communication
that we allow in extensions.
When you use an IFrame,
you can just call functions
directly inside that frame,
assuming the frame
is in the same origin.
And that's exactly the same way
it works in extensions.
You can get a reference
to all the different web pages
in your extension at any time,
and you can just call
functions on them.
So it works exactly
the same way as frames.
I can--I have a sample of this.
I have this configuration page
that I'm gonna add
to my extension.
And you can see that
it's a very simple web page.
It just has one checkbox,
and what this checkbox
is gonna do
is when it's checked,
it's gonna show
the number of unread items
in my reading list,
and when it's unchecked,
it won't show them.
So maybe this is useful
if people want to save space
in their toolstrip or something.
And you can see it works
just like a regular web page.
There's an onchange
event handler.
It calls this function,
and here's the interesting part.
It calls chrome.self.getViews,
which gets a reference
to all the pages
that are part of your extension.
And it iterates through them.
And...for each one,
it looks to see if it has
that unread count span
that we added
which would mean
it's a toolstrip.
And if it is a toolstrip,
then it sets the visibility
of that span,
depending on whether
the checkmark is checked or not.
So this is useful.
So again,
I'll restart my extension.
And you could, of course,
add UI to your extension
to access
the configuration page.
But I'm just,
for expediency,
gonna type in the URL
directly.
Every--
Since extensions
are web pages,
they have a URL,
and it works exactly
the same way as regular URLs.
And this long number here
is the extension's unique ID.
And since I'm in development
mode right now,
these IDs are just--
they're just incrementing
numbers,
so the first one is zero,
the second one's one, etcetera,
just to explain what that is.
And...so I have
my settings here,
all my complex settings.
And if I check this thing,
you can see
that number goes away...
comes back, and...
if I had multiple
of these pages open...
I don't know if I can fit...
let's see.
Yeah. So now I have
three of these open,
and you can see
they all come and go.
So this is how communication
works inside of an extension.
Now, some of you
may be thinking, that's cool,
you can communicate
between pages.
But if you've worked on
other systems like this before,
you may be wondering--like
it would be really confusing
to have all of these web pages
coming and going all the time
whenever browser windows
open and close
and whatever sidebars
open and close,
and you have all this code
running all over the place,
but there's no one in charge.
There's no chunk of code
that's in charge
of the entire extension.
So it becomes a little bit
like distributed programming,
because you have to manage
all these peers
and get them to...
cooperate.
And that can be really hard,
and it's a frustrating way
to program.
And it would be
much more easy
if there was a single place
that you could run code
in your extension
that would exist for the entire
lifetime of the extension
and wouldn't be attached
to any particular window.
Oops.
And...yeah?
[man speaking indistinctly]
Goodman: Yeah.
It...yeah.
Except for the--
the question is
is there a same origin
restriction
on the web pages
inside Chrome Extensions?
And the answer is, yes,
the same origin policy applies
except for
the cross-origin XHR.
So...for this exact reason,
we introduce the concept
of the background page.
And the background page
is another web page.
Again,
exactly the same thing
as the other parts
of the system.
It's just a web page.
And the background page
is basically just a web page
that is not attached
to any browser window
and is not visible.
So it's totally invisible,
you can't see it,
but it's running.
And the idea is
that you put all the main part
of your extension code in here
so that you don't have
to worry about it
coming and going
as browser windows come and go.
And then the UI
of your extension
just becomes like a view,
a dumb view,
and when it needs information
from your extension,
it requests it
from the background page.
And when your background page
notices some state change,
it updates all the views.
So this works out pretty well.
And I can demonstrate, again,
with my extension,
building up the complexity
of my extension here
little bit by little bit.
What we can do
with this extension
is right now we have--
every toolstrip is contacting
the Reader API itself,
so whenever I create
a new window,
I end up contacting
the Reader API twice.
Which, besides just being
inconsiderate,
is just not that good.
So it would be better
if we moved all that code
into the background page
so that it only happens once
for the entire extension.
So we can go ahead and do that.
I'll just...very simply copy
all of my code from my toolstrip
into the new background page.
I'll save this
as background.html.
Now, I'm not gonna need the UI
because, again,
the background page
is invisible.
So I'll delete that.
And this setCount function,
right now what it's doing
is it's for the toolstrip,
so it's just updating the UI
directly.
That's not gonna work because
it's a background page
and it's invisible.
So instead,
what we need to do
is tell all the toolstrips
to update themselves.
So I have a function here...
so I'll replace the
implementation of this function
to do something else.
And again, it's gonna call it
chrome.self.getViews.
It's gonna iterate
through all the views
and look and see if they
have a particular function,
and if they do,
it will call that function,
basically telling the view,
hey, the unread count
has changed.
You need to update yourself.
The other thing
I'm gonna do
is add this global variable.
And you'll see
what that's for in a second.
Now I need to change
the actual toolstrip itself...
because I no longer need
all this code
that's in the toolstrip...
because I moved it
to the background page.
So my new toolstrip code
is very simple.
It's just a few lines again.
On load, it's gonna call
the function to update itself,
and what that's gonna do
is go through all the views
and look for
the background page.
When it finds
the background page,
it will use that global
variable that I created
to update its count.
And the same function
is the same one
that's gonna get called
when the background page notices
that things have changed.
So the final thing
I need to do
is register my background page,
tell the extension system
that it exists...
and then it should be
ready to go.
So again, I'll start Chrome.
You can see that it still works,
which is a good sign.
If I create multiple windows,
it's still going.
That's good.
But other than that,
it's pretty much the same.
You can tell
that something has happened
by going to this
management page that we have.
This will eventually--
this is obviously early UI.
But this will become
the management UI
for the extension system.
And it shows you all the
extensions you have installed,
and right now
I just have one.
And it also shows you
all the views in your extension.
And you can see there's two--
the toolstrip
and the background page.
And if I create another one,
another browser window,
and refresh,
now I have two toolstrips.
So that makes sense.
And there's also a button here
to inspect them,
so I can actually inspect
the background page.
So you use the inspector
on the background page.
And it might not seem
that useful
to inspect an invisible page,
but one thing you can do
is use
Chrome's new fancy
visual de-bugger.
So we now have a visual
JavaScript de-bugger for Chrome,
which is fun.
And it was written
for web pages,
but again, since extensions
are web pages,
it works for extensions too,
so you can set break points
and stuff like that.
Which is good.
Another thing I can do
with this background page
is maybe it would be useful
to have a manual
refresh button...
in my extension
so that I could--
if I wanted to know
how many--
like right now, my extension,
all it does at startup is
it checks how many items
are in my reading list.
It would be better if I could
refresh it whenever I wanted.
So I can...update my toolstrip
really easily to support that.
I'll add this function
that does the refresh...
to my toolstrip.
And again,
all this does is
it goes through all the views,
finds the background page
and calls the function
to refresh.
And I will add a new button
to call the function,
the refresh function.
And...if I restart,
I now have a refresh button.
I can go to Google Reader.
Maybe I want to read some stuff.
As I make the count
go down a little bit,
you can see that
it still says 610.
But I have actually only 600.
If I press refresh...
it changes to 600.
And if I have multiple pages...
And I take it down to 590
and I press refresh
in one of them,
both of them update...
using the background page.
So that's good.
The last thing I want to point
out about the process model
is the effect that it has
on the browser APIs.
These are those narrow
browser APIs
I talked about earlier.
An interesting thing happens
when you try to do browser APIs
in a multiprocess browser.
The problem is that all the APIs
that you want to write
are manipulating data
that exist in another process.
So your extension
is running in one process,
but the tab system
for the browser
is running in a different
process from the extension.
So at a low level,
fundamentally, what's happening
is that the extension process
has to send a message
to the browser process,
asking it to create a tab.
And then the browser process
has to send a message
back to the extension process
saying,
hey, I created the tab
you asked for--here it is.
And so this is an asynchronous
environment,
and fundamentally,
this is just the situation.
And...
so we thought about
how to deal with this,
because async programming
can be difficult,
and one thing that we
could potentially do
is try to paper it over
and make it look like
it's synchronous.
But the problem with that
is that if you try to pretend
that an asynchronous system
is really synchronous,
you can end up
with conflicts and situations
where the API tells you
the state is one thing,
but in reality,
it's something else.
And that ends up being
even more confusing.
And so what we decided was
instead of trying
to paper this over,
we would use some of the idioms
and techniques
that web developers
are already familiar with
for working with
asynchronous systems
and just use them
so that at least,
although you have to use
asynchronous APIs,
it's using a technique
that you're familiar with
and using patterns that
you're familiar with.
So if you just think
of the browser as the server
for your extension web page,
it works pretty much the same.
We've designed the APIs
so that they look very similar
to AJAX APIs.
You pass in an object
that is a JSON-style object,
and you get back results
that are JSON-style objects.
So if you're familiar with
doing AJAX programming,
this should look
pretty similar to you.
So the last cool thing
about the extension system
that I want to talk about
is packaging and distribution.
So I've convinced you
that this is really cool,
and you go and you write
your extension
and now you want to let
your friends use it
or let your users
or customers use it.
I mentioned earlier
that extensions are zip files,
and that's true.
But they also have two
special pieces of information
stuck onto the front of them.
And because they have these
extra pieces of information,
we package them
as special files
with a special extension
called CRX,
which stands for
Chrome Extension.
The first piece of information
that's tacked onto the front
is the signature.
And all extensions in Chrome
are digitally signed.
And the reason for that
is it prevents against
a really common attack
called a Man-in-the-Middle
attack
where basically
the signature tells you,
tells Chrome that when you
update an extension
that the person
who wrote the update
is the same person who wrote
the original extension.
So it can't be substituted
with malicious code.
And we also tack a manifest
onto the front,
and the manifest
is the exact same manifest
that is inside the zip file,
which might seem kind of funny
to have the same data twice,
but we do it for a good reason.
And the reason is
we want to show UI right away
when you install an extension.
Again, we want the experience
of using extensions
to be really polished
and fit with Chrome.
And so when you click
on an extension on the web,
we don't want to have to wait
for the entire extension
to download to show UI.
We want to show UI right away,
and we want to show UI that says
this is extension blah,
it has this description,
here's its icon,
here's what it wants to do, etc.
And so we put the manifest
on the front
so that as soon as we get this
first few packets of data,
we can start displaying UI.
Now, I'm just bringing this up
because I think
it's an interesting detail,
but you don't have to worry
about this.
As an extension developer,
typically, you won't deal
with CRX files directly.
Goggle is going to provide
a service
that does the packaging,
a web service.
And you'll just upload
a zip file,
and it will be packaged
into a CRX file for you,
and that's the end of the story.
So once you have your CRX file,
you want to deploy it.
You want to put it someplace
so people can install it.
Deployment of Chrome Extensions
is trivial.
You copy the CRX file
to your web server,
and that's pretty much it.
Or you mail it
or whatever you need to do.
Installation
of Chrome Extensions is instant.
There's no restart.
They show up immediately.
And we're so proud of this,
'cause it just got finished
recently.
Then I'm gonna show it off.
So you can do a Google search
for Chrome Extensions samples
and...there's a bunch
of sample extensions
that we've posted
on our developer's site
that you can install.
Let's see...I'll do...
the buildbot one.
So the little dialog comes up,
and it shows up immediately.
And this one has
this cool feature
where, if you hover over it,
it like expands
and shows you more information.
Ha. If you're not familiar
with what a buildbot is,
it's basically a system that
lets the developers of Chrome
know what the status
of the Chrome source code is
at any given time.
So this is telling me that
Chrome source code
is in a good state right now,
but there is
one red breakage.
So this one broke something.
Anyway, um...
so installation is instant.
And similarly,
un-installation is also instant.
If I go to that same
management page...
now I have two extensions.
I uninstall the buildbot one.
It goes away immediately.
And again, you don't have
to worry about hosting.
If you don't want to host
your own CRX files,
Google will provide
a web service that you can use
to host your CRX files.
You just upload them,
and nothing to it.
Once you get your extension
deployed
and people are using it
and it's pop--yes?
[man speaking indistinctly]
Goodman: Oh. Okay.
[man continues indistinctly]
Goodman: Right.
The question is,
will there be a warning
if you host it
from your own site
versus hosting it from
the official site?
We haven't figured out
the details of the UI there.
It's something that we're
still trying to design,
so I can't answer that question
specifically.
It's definitely something
that we've considered
because...there's definite
security risks
from installing extensions
from arbitrary websites.
man: Can you use
the CRX generating service
in an automated tool
like...you know,
just upload and automatically
then download onto your site?
I mean, if you wanted
to deploy something
in a script?
Goodman: The question is,
will you be able to use
the packaging tool
in a automated script?
man: Yeah.
Goodman: Okay.
That's not something
we've thought about--
like making it a web service.
But one thing
I forgot to mention
is that the format of CRX
is completely open,
and we'll have Python scripts
that you can use.
We already have a Python script
that you can use to create them.
And the format is trivial--
it's like a zip file
with some extra bytes
appendaged to the front, so...
And, of course,
Chrome is open source,
so you could look at
the source code too.
So basically
what I'm getting at
is you may not be able to use
our web service to do that,
but if you're willing
to write code,
you could easily write code
to create CRX files.
So you have your extension.
People are using it.
And then you discover
there's a bug in it,
so you want to update it.
You could do a blog post,
telling people, hey,
you should get the new
version of my extension.
But it would be better
if you could update
all the existing users
of your extension.
And the extension system
in Chrome
works exactly the same way
as the update system
for Chrome itself.
Updates of Chrome Extensions
are automatic.
There's no work required
by users.
There's no manual update step.
There's never a prompt that
tells users they need to update
or restart
when they get the update.
And users always have
the latest version.
And we think this is
a great feature for users
and it helps
with security too.
Additionally, updates in Chrome,
as I mentioned before,
because of those narrow APIs,
Chrome Extensions
are forward-compatible.
So you never have to declare
in your extension
what versions of Chrome
that your extension
is compatible with.
Because once you use an API
that we have released
to the stable channel,
we guarantee
that we won't break you.
So you don't have to worry
about updating your extension
when new versions
of Chrome come out.
And again,
like the other things,
Google is going to provide
an update service
that takes care of the
auto-update protocol for you
so you won't have to do it
yourself,
but again, the update protocol
is going to be open
and all the formats are open,
so if you want to do it
yourself,
you'll be able to.
Finally, we're gonna...
I mentioned
that we're gonna have services
for packaging
for hosting and for update,
and similarly,
we'll have a gallery service
where users can go
to find extensions
that they might want
to install
and where developers
can post their extensions
if they want people
to install them.
We don't have any--
we're still working on
the design for this right now.
It's a work in progress,
so we don't have
anything to show you.
But we hope to be able
to show this really soon.
And, uh, that's it.
So I hope this has been
informative
and piqued your interest
and that you'll get started
building Chrome Extensions.
If you want to learn
how to do it again,
do a Google search for
Chrome Extensions HOWTO.
It'll take you to
a really simple tutorial
that walks you through it.
You can talk to--
there's a bunch of extension
developers here today--
not extension developers,
but people who work
on the extension system.
And we're gonna be having
something called a Sandbox
at 1:00 today
and office hours tomorrow
from 1:00 to 3:00,
so you can talk to us then.
You can obviously
talk to me after this.
Or you can email us
at chromium-discuss
at googlegroups.com.
And with that,
I will open it up to questions.
[applause]
For the questions,
please go to the microphones,
because we're recording this,
and that way people
who watch it later on YouTube
will be able
to hear the questions.
man: For the cross...
cross-origin XHR...
Goodman: Yeah.
man: Will the Chrome
Extension honor
the W3C HTTP header
properties?
Goodman: Yes.
The question is will Chrome--
man: From the server.
Goodman: Right.
Will Chrome Extensions
support the opt-in W3C header
for cross-origin XHR?
And the answer is yes,
because Chrome Extensions
are web pages.
They just inherit
all the features of Chrome.
And Chrome itself
already supports that,
and so Chrome Extensions
do too.
The cross-origin XHR
that extensions have
is more powerful
than the W3C one,
because it allows you
to talk to servers
that have not opted in
to receiving cross-origin--
man: So it's a way
for the web page author
to bypass the...
Goodman: It's a way
for extensions to--
man: External servers...
HTTP headers is...
Goodman: Right.
It allows Chrome Extensions
to access web servers
on other origins
regardless of the header.
Exactly.
man: Oh, okay. Thank you.
Goodman: Yep.
man: Is there, uh...
is there any thought
or concern
about the security risks
involved in extensions
that, uh...
is there any concern about
the transparent update
of extensions
in terms of the security,
like somebody making
a simple little extension
and then transparently
updating it with malicious code?
It would be difficult
maybe for users
to even figure out
which extensions caused--
Goodman: Right.
Great question.
The question is
is there any concern about,
with the transparent update,
that an extension
starts out BIN again,
but then it becomes malicious?
And, yes, there is
concern about that.
In the talk,
there's a lot of cool things
about the system that
we just didn't have time
to put in the talk.
But one of them is that
we have this opt-in
permission system
where extensions
have to declare
which permissions they want.
And if an update of
an extension changes the list,
then you have to go through
a proper installation phase
again.
So it brings up UI
that asks the user,
"Hey, do you want to install
this thing?"
and shows the permissions
and things like that.
man: Excellent. Thank you.
Goodman: Yep.
man: I love Greasemonkey,
by the way.
So I'm just curious...
would you say that
we'll be able to do
a Greasemonkey-like extension
on Chrome soon?
Goodman: The question is,
will you be able to do
Greasemonkey-like things
on Chrome?
Yes, the extension system
currently includes
Greasemonkey-like functionality.
That's another thing that I
wasn't able to fit in the talk.
We're still trying to figure out
the details
of exactly
how it's gonna work.
There's a lot of different ideas
that we're throwing around.
But the current
developer builds of Chrome
already include
this functionality.
And if you go to
the Chrome Extensions HOWTO,
it shows you how to do that.
man: Cool. I know you guys
can't talk about specific dates,
but--and I'll leave
after this--
but as a developer that's
actually shipping product,
it really helps to have
some kind of time window
even without a specific date.
Goodman: Yeah.
man: You know, 'cause I mean,
I don't want to develop
something that's a year out.
Goodman: Yep.
man: But can you give me
even like a window of...
If you were developing today
and you had to ship something
in six months,
would it make sense
to be using this now?
Goodman: Unfortunately,
I, of course, haven't--
The question is,
when are we gonna ship it?
The answer is
yes, I have an idea
of when we're gonna ship it,
but no, I can't tell you.
Sorry.
man: I'll talk to you later.
I'll talk to you later
when it's not being recorded.
[laughing]
Goodman: Sorry--
[woman speaking indistinctly]
Goodman: Okay, so I can't
answer any more questions.
[continues indistinctly]
Goodman: Okay, all right.
So I'm told that
we can talk outside.
Thank you, everyone,
for coming.
[applause]